لقد رأينا نوعًا من المحاور في هذه
المنطقة نحو الصين
وبالفعل روسيا الأكثر انتهازية
وبعيدًا عن
أه الولايات المتحدة عند الحاجة وعندما يكون ذلك
مناسبًا
أه هناك أه كل أه كل
فرصة أن أه ولي العهد أه
برؤيته 2030
وقد يتجه الإنفاق والمصروفات
المرتبطة بذلك
إلى
الشركات الصينية أه الشركات الروسية
والشركات الأوكرانية وأقل
تجاه الولايات المتحدة في المضي قدمًا مما قد يكون
ضارًا جدًا
لواشنطن
وهذا شيء بالتأكيد
ستكون واشنطن على دراية به وأعتقد
هذا هو المكان الذي نسمع فيه أن
إدارة بايدن تقول كما تعلم
بينما نحن نوعًا ما لن
ندعم الحرب في اليمن ، سنقوم
بدعم الدفاع عن المملكة العربية السعودية
لتوضيح للمملكة أنها حليف كبير
أن التاريخ  نوع من
الاجتماعات الطويلة بين الملوك
والرؤساء السابقين وهذا ليس
شيئًا سيتغير هذه هي
الرسالة ولكنك محق تمامًا
أعني أن هناك قدرًا كبيرًا  اقتصاديًا
ومصلحة اقتصادية متزايدة
بين الصين
والمملكة العربية السعودية وبالتأكيد
كان للرئيس بوتين علاقات وثيقة جدًا
مع الملك سلمان
وولي العهد محمد بن سلمان ، لذلك
أعتقد أنك إذا كنت أنت
إذا كنت من الولايات المتحدة.
كتفك من قد يأخذ
مكانك في تلك العلاقة ،
هناك بالتأكيد آخرون ينتظرون هناك
والمملكة العربية السعودية
تتحدث إلى شخص قريب
من صندوق الاستثمار الكبير في البلاد
مؤخرًا
وقد أوضحوا تمامًا أن
الاستثمارات التي تقوم بها المملكة
هي من أجل المصلحة الوطنية.
ستكون استثمارات جيدة وإذا
اعتقدوا أن هذا ليس ما قيل
لي ولكن إذا اعتقدوا أن المعنى هو
ما إذا كانوا يعتقدون أنهم
سيكون لديهم استثمارات سليمة
في آسيا ، فسوف يتابعون ذلك وهذا من
بالطبع هو الشيء
الذي يريد الرئيس بايدن أم تجنبه
من فعل الديمقراطيات الأصيلة
وهو الاستثمار في
الصين عندما يكون لديها مثل هذا الرجل  y انتهاكات حقوق
الإنسان
، وكان من المثير للاهتمام أن ننظر إلى
ما حدث في المملكة العربية السعودية فيما يتعلق
بحقوق الإنسان
في الأسابيع الأخيرة ، والإفراج
عن
بعض النشطاء البارزين أو الإفراج الجزئي عن بعض النشطاء البارزين الذين
كانوا رهن الاعتقال لفترة من
الوقت
تلك الرسالة.  من الرسالة
تتجذر أيضًا في المملكة العربية السعودية إلى
متى ينحنيون فقط في
نسيم حقوق الإنسان في بايدن هنا ليس واضحًا.